saison après saison toujours les mêmes
conseils on laisse tomber dedans depuis
neuf ans hiver comme été flora travail à
métabief en tant que saisonnière
une activité qui lui sied bien aux
remontées mécaniques l'était ce qui est
chouette c'est le contact clientèle
c'est le relationnel avoir le temps de
d'expliquer que ce soit au biker mais
aussi aux piétons de leur parler de
l'environnement des montagnes
environnantes
comme elle une trentaine de saisonniers
reviennent chaque été à la station une
spécificité garantie par un cadre
juridique
le cdd sur une station de ski et en
particulier celle qui prend la
convention collective des remontées
mécaniques et domaine skiable
c'est que le saisonnier au bout d'une
première saison concluante acquiert une
reconduction
c'est à dire que deux saisons en saisons
il a priorité de réembauche et que de
saison en saison il peut venir et
continuer à travailler à la station
fidéliser ces travailleurs estivaux
une exception notable dans les stations
de montagne quelques mètres plus loin
dans ce restaurant
gilles peine à recruter des saisonniers
d'année en année il ya moins en moins de
jeunes qui qui envoient leurs cv les
étés précédents on avait 20 à 30 36 des
pourpoints travail de serveurs ou en
salle cette année en a reçues 5 vous
avez la suite
l'attractivité de la suisse qui fait que
les jeunes préfèrent les là-bas rangs
des petits boulots même de petits
l'emploi ou les salaires sont beaucoup
plus élevés nous la restauration c'est
pas un métier qui est le plus attirant
pour les jeunes notamment au niveau des
horaires chaque année les professionnels
du secteur doivent s'adapter pour faire
face à une affluence toujours plus
importante de touristes